تعيش ميشيل بينيت وأطفالها
في خوف من
أن صاحب المنزل يحاول طردهم
بعد أن فقدت وظيفتها ولا يمكنها دفع
الإيجار ،
ليس لدي حقًا أي مكان أذهب إليه
معي ، ليس لديّ
دخل لأدفعه أثناء الوباء
لأنني لا أملك  لا نريد أن نكون بلا مأوى ، فإن
أزمة الإخلاء
ليست سوى واحدة من الكوارث الاقتصادية
التي تواجه إدارة بايدن ،
بما في ذلك فقدان الوظائف التاريخي
وأزمة الجوع المتزايدة
الأسبوع الماضي ، وقع الرئيس بايدن
أمرًا تنفيذيًا يمدد حظر
عمليات الإخلاء خلال المسيرة ،
لكن هذا لا يساعد  بينيت ، التي
يقول محاميها إن مالكها
يستخدم ثغرة أصبحت أكثر شيوعًا
خلال الوباء ،
لقد بدأت بالفعل في تعبئة خطة تحفيز بايدن البالغة 1.9
تريليون دولار تقترح
حوالي 30 مليارًا كمساعدة إيجارية
إضافية لأشهر حاولت بينيت التقديم حتى
تتمكن من البقاء في منزلها
دون أي حظ  عندما تتصل ، يبدو الأمر وكأنه لا
توجد أموال تعرفها أو تعاود الاتصال الشهر المقبل ،
فأنت تعلم أنه ربما سيكون هناك مال
ثم تعرف
، ثم يمكنك إعادة الاتصال  في ذلك الوقت ، الشهر المقبل
، لا يزال الأمر كذلك ، لقد نفدنا المال ، لقد خرجت
مطالبات البطالة الأسبوعية
تحوم حول المليون
، وفي الشهر الماضي ، تخلص الاقتصاد من الوظائف
لأول مرة منذ أبريل ،
كل واحد من هؤلاء 140 ألفًا
الوظائف
المفقودة كانت تشغلها امرأة ، رايلي هي واحدة من
هذه الوظائف
، إنه لأمر محبط أنها
هزمت رايلي.
أكثر من ذلك ،
ما زال أمامنا طريق طويل لنقطعه قبل
أن يشعر مجتمعنا الاقتصادي حقًا ويقدر
ما يجب على الإناث المساهمة به في
المجتمع
ما هو بلد غذاء بدون طعام حيث
تستمر 19 حالة شهوة في صعود
بنوك الطعام في جميع أنحاء
البلاد.  تقول الحكومة التي
تمول الحملة ضد الجوع في
بروكلين نيويورك إن أموالهم أوشكت على النفاد ،
إنه أمر مخيف لا أعرف ما
الذي سأفعله لأنني  لا يزال لدي
طعام لأشتريه وقع الرئيس بايدن
أمرًا تنفيذيًا لمعالجة
الجوع يوجه وزارة
الزراعة لمنح العائلات المزيد من المال
لاستبدال وجبات الغداء
المدرسية وزيادة قسائم الطعام لنحو 12
مليون أمريكي ،
لكن البعض على حافة الهاوية سيظل يسقط من
خلال الشقوق
و  تحتاج بنوك الطعام إلى تمويل فيدرالي
لإطعامها ،
أحتاج إلى ضمانات من جميع صانعي السياسات لدينا
الذين يستمعون
إليك بدأت أنت بحاجة إلى إنهاء هذا
الشيء ،
لقد بدأنا في مساعدة العائلات لا يمكننا
تركها في فراغ